[Música]
[Aplausos]
no es la primera vez que me presentan
como ingeniero pero claro no es una
novedad porque piensan que hace un
abogado en una empresa automotriz si soy
abogado y ya que empezamos con esa
presentación de ingeniero explico un
poco y para esto nos remontamos unos
años atrás bueno bastantes años atrás
luego de salir de la universidad de la
facultad de derecho tenía algo clarísimo
con toda la determinación estudiar en el
extranjero hacer una maestría y de poder
hacerlo en otro idioma para perfeccionar
y donde llegué llegué a holanda y donde
hablando en groningen que es una ciudad
que tiene el más alto número de
bicicletas per cápita y si estamos
hablando de holanda posiblemente desde
las regiones con más bicicletas en el
mundo la vida va en torno a la bicicleta
usas la bicicleta para todo para ir al
colegio los niños van al kinder en
bicicletas universidad trabajo el primer
ministro va a trabajar en bicicleta y
para ir a la universidad no es la
excepción pero como dice un amigo
diplomático holanda y los países
nórdicos son pues países climáticamente
tercermundistas y esto
era un clásico de llegar recuerdo llegar
a la universidad a la biblioteca para
estudiar en época de exámenes
estudiábamos de 9 a la mañana a 11 de la
noche y estos eran mis calcetines récord
de estar en el baño exprimiendo los
calcetines y quedarme todo el día en la
biblioteca esa era la realidad
terminamos la maestría y otra cosa que
tenía claro era volver al país para
seguir en el bufete un bufete yo soy
segunda generación de abogados
pensé oye si está en holanda moviéndome
en bicicleta ahora dónde voy a
cochabamba bolivia una ciudad plana con
un clima excelente distancias cortas
dije no yo me voy a mover en bicicleta
llegaba a la oficina
colorado pero colorado pero no era por
el calor o el esfuerzo era por la furia
la furia porque cada cinco minutos
atentaban contra mi vida
los transportistas esto no podía
continuar así apoye a un grupo de gente
de la masa crítica masa crítica es un
movimiento que nace en san francisco y
que está en muchas ciudades del mundo y
me metí de cabeza para apoyar a sacar la
ley municipal de la bicicleta como una
iniciativa ciudadana fue una pelea muy
larga dura tomándonos con una pared de
autoridades no veían el beneficio no
había un interés económico pero
estábamos seguros de que iba que había
que seguir ese camino pensando también
que esa norma tenga un artículo muy
importante que es el de la educación
porque todo cambio se hace con educación
finalmente después de mucho esfuerzo se
promulgó la ley de la bicicleta las
autoridades la sacaron como si fuera una
cosa suya
olvidando que fue todo más bien en
contra y fue pues un orgullo haber
sacado esta ley entonces ahí me di
cuenta que es posible hacer un agente de
cambio hacer la diferencia en la
sociedad
posteriormente a eso yo de abogado
ejerciendo de abogado con tenía un
cliente y gran amigo jose carlos márquez
en la idea de oye podemos hacer los
autos eléctricos en bolivia
obviamente eso suena muy difícil pero
pues empezamos a pensar y el plan era
hacer este auto
nos pusimos a conversar
pensamos en los detonantes ambos tenemos
hijos muy pequeñitos vivimos en la
ciudad más contaminada de bolivia y una
de las ciudades más contaminadas de
latinoamérica y veíamos que nadie hacía
algo para contrarrestar esto
donde estamos en bolivia que tiene nada
más y nada menos que las mayores
reservas de litio del mundo un elemento
esencial para los autos eléctricos no
había que hacer un gurú para darse
cuenta que la movilidad eléctrica era el
futuro
tras muchos tiempos de
pelearla de desarrollo e investigación
sacamos un auto un auto sumamente
económico eléctrico cámara de retro
vidrios eléctricos encendido con botón
etcétera para tres personas un gran paso
para bolivia teníamos los autos
sorpresa no podíamos comercializar
nuestros autos porque porque la
legislación no estaba contemplada la
posibilidad de un auto nacional y decían
quieres que lo registremos en el sistema
dame tu póliza de importación
qué póliza de importación si lo hemos
hecho acá
y esto va de la mano de otras cosas
cuando estábamos en el proyecto okay
hablemos con proveedores para el vidrio
por ejemplo vidrio para autos bolivianos
no no hay autos en bolivia no pero vamos
a hacer no no hay bueno necesitaremos
financiamiento para que los clientes
compren el auto que auto el que vamos a
hacer no pero no conocemos el récord
cuánto tiempo funcionan los autos
eléctricos no hay autos eléctricos en
bolivia bueno pero va a haber no no se
puede tenemos que asegurar el auto
empresas aseguradoras no tenemos el
récord no no podemos no sabemos cómo
funciona esto no no no los argumentos no
eran válidos lo que nos dábamos cuenta
ya que era una falta de fe en la
posibilidad de que haya un auto
boliviano salimos a la luz pública un 12
de septiembre del 2019 exactamente hace
dos años y empezaron a sonar los
teléfonos te vendemos el vídeo te
mandamos los frenos vengan a almorzar
para ver que
mi seguro es el mejor ahora trabajamos
con más de ocho bancos que financian
nuestros productos entonces fue un
cambio muy grande
y ahora el presente creo que estamos
viviendo la
transformación de la matriz energética
en la movilidad urbana
tenemos los autos tenemos los triciclos
destinados a hacer el mototaxi de
bolivia el triciclo de carga bicicletas
y motocicletas todo eléctrico pero
cuando nosotros no nosotros cuando todos
hablamos de autos eléctricos te viene a
la cabeza esa gran marca de autos de
autos muy caros el auto eléctrico que
tenemos en nuestro país no es un auto
caro es un auto que está destinado para
la base de la pirámide es un cambio de
matriz energética inteligente
empezando por la base de la pirámide de
la pirámide que tienen menos recursos
económicos pero es la más grande así
tenemos todos los bolivianos y los
latinoamericanos la posibilidad de
contar con un auto con un vehículo
eléctrico
a propósito esta empresa empresa
boliviana fue la primera de bolivia y
pionera en latinoamérica en lo que es
micro movilidad eléctrica lo cual para
nosotros es un orgullo y fruto del
nacimiento de quántum fue pues que las
repercusiones fueron muy grandes
noticias en rusia- cnn euronews y
univision de todos los países limítrofes
de hecho esta noticia era del perú
[Risas]
entonces aquí venimos con lo que es la
transformación ambiental automotriz
miran a un auto eléctrico y esto qué
significa ahora vemos que significa
hagamos un eje un un ejercicio básico
cuanto más vendió aproximadamente
800 vehículos eléctricos con vehículos
me refiero a autos tres ciclos de carga
tres ciclos de personas bicicletas y
motocicletas pero hagamos un ejercicio
solo con 350 vehículos si calculamos que
transitan 30 kilómetros al día por 30
días estamos haciendo una disminución de
39.3 toneladas de dióxido de carbono
mensual una empresa tan pequeña de un
país
en desarrollo de la tercera ciudad en
cochabamba ha logrado disminuir
39.3 toneladas de dióxido de carbono en
un mes se imaginan si más gente apuesta
por negocios como este con un enfoque
del liderazgo responsable
apuntando hacia un futuro sustentable
y que esto naturalmente se transmita a
la población y que sigue este rumbo
eso haría la diferencia y no es una
diferencia optativa es una diferencia
que puede ser la diferencia entre que
sigamos en un planeta con las
condiciones actuales o la debacle no lo
digo yo lo dicen los científicos
además de este beneficio ambiental lo
que se ha logrado con esta empresa es
cambiar la legislación nacional primero
después también de todos impacto
mediático de la vergüenza de que un auto
boliviano no pueda transitar en las
calles se sacó la normativa para que sea
legal registrar en el sistema autos
merín bolivia off que orgullo ahora
cualquier empresa puede hacerlo fuimos
la punta de lanza del cambio en la
legislación nacional automotriz
posterior a esto un municipio sacó la
ley de de exenciones tributarias
nuestros autos del primer año no pagas
impuestos segundo año 50% de rebaja
tercer año
5 de rebaja porque porque tenemos una
cara bonita no
porque es una cuestión de salud pública
estado llámese estado central
departamental o municipal va a erogar
menos dinero para salud cuando decimos
una contaminación muy grande allá pero
cuando lo pones que 1 de cada 10
personas muere por problemas
respiratorios
ya es tangible el problema otra vez no
lo digo yo son datos de la organización
mundial de la salud entonces ya tenemos
la ley la primera ley tributaria a nivel
municipal y finalmente hace un tiempo el
estado central ha sacado una una
normativa por la que da incentivos
tributarios y financieros para las
fábricas de vehículos eléctricos y a la
gente que quiera comprar porque por
buenas gentes no
macroeconomía qué pasa en bolivia
bolivia actualmente subvención a los
hidrocarburos si no estoy equivocado el
año 2018 es una subvención de 1.700
millones de bolivianos que salen de
nuestros impuestos de nuestra reserva lo
que sea para financiar el precio de los
hidrocarburos
además los importamos eso por un lado y
por otro lado tenemos energía que nos
sobra por las orejas producimos 3 mil
350 megawatts orea higa y sólo gastamos
1700 es decir tenemos un excedente del
50% y dada la tecnología actual no
podemos acumular esa energía o sea que
se pierde y mientras tanto pagamos el
mantenimiento de esas plantas personales
etcétera etcétera entonces hoy voy a
seguir subvencionando esto que no tengo
o voy a gastar esto que me sobra esa es
la razón por la que sale este tipo de
cosas y la movilidad eléctrica es el
futuro
yo bailé en saco un tweet hace menos de
dos semanas diciendo el futuro de la
movilidad es eléctrico y no hay vuelta
atrás hay una prueba más clara que el
presidente de eeuu diga esto creo que no
no solo este este beneficio lo que esta
transformación ambiental automotriz no
solo va en lo ambiental y en lo legal
sino también
algo que nos afecta al bolsillo otra vez
hagamos un ejercicio muy simple 350
autos 30 kilómetros al día esto hace
durante un mes 315 mil kilómetros esto
en gasolina en bolivia son 17 mil
dólares esto en cualquier otro país
sería exactamente el doble el precio
internacional es el doble de la actual
en bolivia y lo mismo con gasolina
serían dos mil perdón con electricidad
son dos mil trescientos dólares estamos
hablando de un ahorro del 86 por ciento
para nuestros bolsillos es una de las
pocas veces que lo ambiental se junta
con lo económico en definitiva pues
una oportunidad de oro que tenemos la
responsabilidad de asumirlo y seguir
pues el camino de la micro movilidad
eléctrica con gusto
[Aplausos]